[Music]
jet they should have a pretty good year
this year Cowboys are obviously going to
miss the playoffs once again calling
eight and8 Sean Watson's going to throw
5,000 yard this is the year that momes
takes second place and he gets to watch
us the playoffs while he's at home Mac
Jones is going to win MVP comeback
season of the year for ma
Jones I'm 17-0 perfect season for
Patriots Bingo to the Super Bowl it's a
c he's going to be fine they ask you how
you are you you just have to say that
you're fine and you're not really fine
Bears going to win the division Fieldy
MVP I'm going to give you the absolute
hottest take first time in NFL history
co- MVPs George Pickins Kenny
Pi this is finally Arthur Smith is
putting it together we are talking about
NFC South Champs